welcome everyone and thank you for
joining us for today's session on
pioneering our understanding of the
human brain I'd like to introduce dr.
wolf Julian Newman who is a clinician
scientist and the movement disorders and
neuromodulation unit in the Department
of Neurology at Shaggy Ted would've
acetates indeed seen Berlin Germany dr.
Newman's work combines computational
modeling deep learning structural and
functional connectivity mapping invasive
and non-invasive recordings to elucidate
the role of the basal ganglia
in health and disease for complete
biography on our speaker please visit
the biography tab at the top of your
screen dr. Newman's soft title is
towards artificial intelligence based
adaptive deep brain stimulation and
movement disorders my name is dr. ocean
Akash William and I will be your
moderator for today's event we were
delighted to bring this educational web
seminar presented by lab words we would
like to extend our special thanks to the
brain initiative program directors in
particular dr. games dad for their
efforts in organizing today's session
before we begin I would like to remind
everyone that this event is interactive
we encourage you to participate by
submitting questions during the
presentation simply click on the ask a
question box located on the far left of
your screen and Tiger questions in the
drop-down box
our speaker will respond to your
questions via email following the
presentation this presentation is
educational and thus offers free
continuing education credits please
click on the continuing education
credits tab located at the top right
corner of the presentation window and
follow the process to obtain your
credits now without further ado please
join me in welcoming dr. Newman okay
thank you for the introduction
now here's my perspective on what is
coming up in the next few years in the
field of deep brain stimulation for
movement disorders for those of you who
don't know deep brain stimulation it's a
very effective treatment for different
movement disorders like Parkinson's
disease Estonian tremor patients who are
not sufficiently
in their symptoms through medication and
therefore then DBS I throat is implanted
into the depths of the brain and
specific targets depending on the
disorder and the indication and another
battery aggregate the so called impulse
generator is implanted under the skin in
the chest or abdominal wall and this
gives opportunity to test functional
connections of the targets and to have a
robust way to develop next-generation
clinical bang computer interfaces
because it's a very effective treatment
that creates reproducible both
behavioral and clinical effects and this
is also inspired by this landmark paper
by Peter Browns group who is an Oxford
and he has shown that deep brain
stimulation can be used in a closed-loop
fashion by recording
electrophysiological activity from the
electrodes that are implanted into the
depths of the brain and using this
electrophysiological activity to trigger
stimulation in real time so here you can
see on the left side the recordings set
up with his DBS electrodes inside the
brain and the signal like an internal or
invasive EEG signal is being captured by
an external computer buyer externalized
each and the stimulation is triggered
dependent on the activity that is
measured and strikingly this publication
could show that even though almost half
only half the time of stimulation was
present it was more effective than
the continuous stimulation paradigm that
is traditionally being used indicating
standstill is the only parent area
vailable treatment or as a model for DBS
and importantly they also controlled for
random pattern stimulation and the 80s
there was triggered by the
electrophysiology was more effective
than either continuous or random pattern
stimulation and this has really inspired
to search for biomarkers and was also
inspired by the fact that we can record
pathological activity that is
characterized dependent on the different
neurological disorders that we are
investigating and as I said biomarkers
are important in this case and we have
in addition to beta activity that was
used in the mentioned publication
characterized many by marks and
different disease and I'm going to
introduce a few to you that are
important in my view in prominent cities
as I said before beta activity in the 13
to 30 Hertz range is the hallmark of the
PD off state so when the patient's we've
been from taking their medication for a
certain time period they develop beta
activity and this can be recorded via
DBS leads from the depths of the basal
ganglia now not only can it be recorded
directly during the surgery or after the
or a few days after surgery it is also
now possible to use implantable devices
to record activity after month of DBS
implantation and we could show that
there is the robust measurement of
activity in the beta frequency range
possible in PD patients when they're off
medication this highlights usefulness
that the biomarker
and not only is it there it also
correlated with these specific symptoms
especially brady kinesia and rigidity
and pd patient but we have also looked
at other movement disorders and dystonia
is a disorder that is associated with
involuntary muscle contractions and in
these patients the internal part of the
target that they can be very effective
in treating this border and we have
characterized circle feet potential from
the pallidum in these patients and found
that both low frequency or theta
injected is typically in the 3 to 12
Hertz range as well as beat activity is
measurable in these patrons but using
different modalities and different
analytical approaches there was only in
towards pathological relevance in the
low frequency of a theater people change
well Peter power was not associated with
building severity in these patients also
neuropsychiatric diseases can be
characterized in the neurologic burner
physiological and on the upper side you
can see our paper on major depressive
disorder here we could record in the
limbic system and anterior cingulate
cortex or the bad nucleus of three
terminals and found that depressed
patients have higher alphabetic the
amount of health oscillations
there are they with death rate in
Tourette's syndrome
another hyperkinetic in the positive
from theta also couple and using
moody variate approach including low
frequency and Peter frequency activity
for both target
it could very reliably predict the
rhythm severity in these patrons
particularly for the motorists though
concluding there are now many different
biomarkers performances in local people
tend to like he and we have a long slide
with other grooves made an effort to
really try and find symptom specific
populations for symptom specific markers
an activity that can be recorded by ITB
feeds and potentially used for those
soup or adaptive BCI application in
tibia and this gives an overview that
with this biggest also puppet in the our
review on this this year and mainly
shows you that there's a lot going on in
the different frequency ranges and in
the low frequency range there is
tendency to - Alicia
so for church buzzards seem to be
associated with adaptive movement where
high activity in the beta frequency
range seems to be associated with lack
of movement I can assure bratty teenager
and rigidity so if we have all these
markers wires artifact is needed and if
we can just use one biomarker and bigger
stimulation whenever that up or I why do
we need more sophisticated computational
approach we have recently characterized
Pacific effects of PBS on specific
pathways in this publication from 2018
where we looked at the effect of
cognitive on current control and
motorists symptoms or in America thing
and this is a study conducted in 20
patients with Parkinsons disease and we
could throw that depending on the
pathway that we're stimulating we're
modulating physiologically relevant or
normal activity via the hyper direct
path back for example and cinematic
aspect and the clinical symptoms of
various modulated mainly be an
interpreter and what this is showing is
not only that the PBS effects depend on
pathways but also on the patient so we
need a camera specificity and we need to
be able to adapt DBS to the current
demand so here I give some example wide
it could help in the clinical setting
some DBS parameters have been reported
to be better for certain symptoms or sir
the behavior in patient for example
improved freezing of gait was before it
hurts
immolation and also through using
ventral DBS tonight instead of the dr.
hammock nucleus so if a patient walks we
might just want to change the simulation
to nothing that is better for working
for bitten well when he said we want to
have the most effective emulation for
wave them but after the motor from then
this kinesia is the problem or the side
effect of medication and stimulation and
many patients pain medication when
they're on libya though the initial on
the clinical ward on the neurological
ward needs to find us having that I'm
somehow balanced the medication effect
that works
whine alongside the chronic DBS now if
we could predict or know when a patient
has dyskinesia
and we could adapt the stimulation
accordingly this could significantly
improve the stability of the clinical
effect in PD patient now finally a
speech can be affected by DBS or also by
the movement disorders and threaten
stimulation settings may improve speech
or even sometimes with using me just
reducing the assimilate Pepa to an
improved oh if we could know when a
patient is speaking that's from
recording an activity we could improve
the outcome of the DBS intervention for
these days so ultimately our long-term
goal should be to develop intelligent
those do adaptive emulation that is an
assistive neural prosthetic and
something that might show us where this
can go
it's the computational model of the
basal ganglia developed by Henning soil
and Fred hunka who created the firing
rate model that can predict behavior in
this publication and have a look at this
3d video of the different brain areas
interact in the model which can predict
behavior actual behavior
you
you
now so what we saw was the interaction
of cortex and basal ganglia and this
kind of reflects the design that I want
to introduce to you here which covers
recording of input and output signals
though most of the biomarkers that I
presented before were recorded in the
actual basal ganglia output path either
the other mod needed but to be able to
create a neural prosthetic we should
have somehow some input into our model
for example as exhibited in the video
before and then we can connect somehow
connect these inputs and output the
neural interface that monitors and
minimizes pathological activity and
create that synthesize a put or a
modulated neural output who stimulated
so to be able to do that we should try
to understand what DBS at bridge as it
are and there's a really amazing study
published in 2018 you buy well Hodgins
proved by the bareheaded by newcomers
also pitch in Toronto and they show they
have thrown the DBS these two local
suppression of Pike firing and to
potentially through gaba mediated
silencing and it also has plastic effect
on gabaergic neuron so this gives that a
good proxy of what is going on the
spiking activity through DBS on the
network level there's another paper I
mean in fact Peter parents groups spared
it by a short while and they have shown
using the Patek was an M eg
at EBS modulate network potentially be a
modulation of by firing but independent
of that our spirit or productivity is
reduced through stimulation in specific
spectrum frequency ranges and also the
paper distribution of these frequency
ranges is different and dependent on the
pathway the portal collectivity seems to
be a relevant property of input not only
based on our anatomical knowledge but
but also on the basis of neuromodulation
that has been shown also by a task for
example great work on the epidemic DVS
more technical activity so this gets us
to the point where we should try and to
think about ways to record particle
activity and Philip star and that
Francisco Rainey has developed or neared
this technique or in movement disorders
using electric photography or a car
strip that can be used potentially for
adaptive DBS and versus the traditional
or big FP recordings this has several
advantages it is compatible with any DBS
electrodes design including segmented
for direct no leads it has a very good
signal to noise ratio compared P it has
the opportunity or gives the opportunity
to taste the sensing electrode
independent of the DBS target and it
allows a large area to be covered the
number of potential stimulation contact
is also an effect but we should remember
that
is additionally avenge invasive and the
clinical uses SP stood so using a cough
we have now investigated the potential
to predict or decode behavior using the
Learning Network based on input signals
that are decomposed into frequency
ranges and we can show in the following
video that it is performing really well
and we can for example the code grouping
force from the patient just based on an
active busy
you
so dr. firmware can be used to move
towards high precision precision
personalized adaptive DBS paradigm using
artificial intelligence by creating
combined acock lfp framework that senses
different features and beats a deep
learning computational network that can
decode poke down with this Adria
freezing of gait walking dyskinesia
tremor
panic panic MPD and then we can use this
information that it decoded from the
interface to adapt the stimulation
parameter that just both with frequency
amplitude in contact now there are open
questions and there is research to be
done in the preclinical state and right
now I want to highlight some of them we
should try to really understand the in
the correlates of MRI connectivity like
fMRI resting stay and oscillations
because Fri is readily available in all
clinical departments while whole had
porto rico that's terrible also for each
officer though if we had a better
knowledge of what is going on in the
crowd and PD we should be able to better
data cockpit in to in the aim to decode
whatever we want to be go then we don't
have good predictors of PD phenotype or
decoding so well if the patient has
hammer or is the body ready kinetic
kinetic rigid kind we don't know yet
whether we should aim for different eco
activity so generally we should analyze
visual patterns of symptom specific
predictors and then we can prototype
sensing montage for optimal prediction
of any
video symptoms using starch cortical
maps derive from all that magnetic the
photography or fMRI connectivity this
concludes my talk I want to like the x2
thank you for your attention and I would
also like to thank my collaborator was
important the Andrea Kuhn who is the
director of a movement disorder in the
relation unit and then our collaborator
that Emil is back who is totally
professor and UCF and Mark Ricketts who
is in Pittsburgh
thank you dr. Norman thank you very much
for that exciting walk as a reminder our
speaker will be available to answer any
questions about his presentation by
email now coming up next we will further
explore the world the cortical basal
ganglia circuit in dr. mark Richardson's
presentation basal ganglia cortical loop
function during speech see there